[MUSIC]
Three years ago, I was sitting at
what I thought to be the perfect job,
I was making six figures working for
a tech company that provided free meals,
unlimited vacation time off and
yes, it did have a nap room.
I thought I had reached
the apex of the American dream.
The American dream that my
parents immigrated from China and
Vietnam to this country for.
And hopes that their child would have
a chance at a better life than they did.
But it didn't feel that way,
I read and watch the news every day.
Over 38 million Americans
are food insecure,
children are being forcibly separated
from their families at the border.
Texas school shooting, Florida school
shooting, voting rights under attack.
Again, my friends and I would turn to each
other in frustration, anger and sadness.
Did you see this,
did you hear this often I cried.
Here I was living this picture
perfect life, but I knew back home in
Philadelphia and across the country,
people were struggling just to survive.
In the neighborhood my
parents first immigrated to,
there are still people who can't afford
to keep a roof over their heads.
Still people can't afford
to put food on the table,
still children are getting asthma from
poor air quality just like I did.
Still in this country we call great,
people are suffering and
dying from rooted injustices.
The American Dream rang hollow.
So, I quit my tech job,
talking about these problems
wasn't going to make them go away.
It wasn't enough to be frustrated,
angry or disappointed.
Everything I had, that my parents
immigrated to this country for
that little, if there are people
still struggling like we once did.
I decided to return home to Philadelphia
to do the job I had done many years ago as
a student, community organizing.
To me the most urgent problem our country
face was that our democracy was in crisis.
So I joined a national organization
working to get out the vote.
In that job I took a 60% pay cut and
had never been pushed to
work harder in my life.
We were expected to work on holidays and
to quote sleep when we are dead.
It was a far cry from the comfortable
Silicon Valley life I was living just
a few months ago.
In that job, I met and
rediscovered community
organizers who had been doing this
work for decades in Philadelphia.
I first met Tina Marie, two years ago
working to get out the vote in Philly.
The work we did was grueling, but it was
made even more difficult, by the pandemic.
Not everyone, could vote in person,
not everyone had Internet access, and
the people with power and
resources didn't seem to care.
Many times I wanted to bang my head
against the wall in frustration,
but Tina Marie never gave up?
She showed up to meetings, she even
used her personal savings to pay for
her neighbor's internet costs.
Tina Marie is over 60 now, but
she has the energy of a teenager.
For over four decades she has been serving
her community, she spends her Wednesdays
attending zoning board meetings,
which can go on for six hours.
She holds countless meetings for her
neighbors to hold developers accountable,
demanding that they invest in home
ownership, not just profit off of rent.
Tina Marie does this
work around the clock,
she works every day into the evenings and
on the weekends to serve her community.
And she does this work for free,
yes, you heard that correctly.
Tina Marie doesn't have
a job that pays her,
serving her community is a full time role.
Why does she do it, you may ask?
Because she says, if she doesn't do it,
no one else will.
Her neighborhood, like many
marginalized neighborhoods across
the country have faced
the same problems for decades.
Lack of quality housing Education, jobs,
imagine living paycheck to paycheck,
sending your kids to
schools with asbestos and
being surrounded by vacant
lots overfilled with trash.
That's a reality that many Americans in
this country still have to face today.
And so you have people like Tina Marie,
and 10s of 1000s of others,
fighting for their communities around the
clock without pay and with little rests,
despite all they have endured,
they're still giving back.
They won't wait why, because they're
fighting for something deeper than money,
prestige or power,
they're fighting for their home.
When his neighbors didn't know
how to vote during the pandemic,
Maurice co-founded
the Philly Voter Engagement Network.
He built a team of hundreds of people
working to spread the vote about mail and
ballot options and polling place changes.
When not enough was done to educate
students about voting Tom co founded pa
youth vote.
He built a coalition of teachers in
more than 40 schools to become voter
champions and empower their
students to take civic action.
When nothing was done about gun
violence in her neighborhood,
Kendra started stand up nice town.
She brought a new resource to our
community every week to change
the conversation, like job readiness
training and counseling services.
When an outside entity tried to take
over her neighborhood public school,
tend to galvanize parents to vote for
it to be kept in the public's control.
And it is through community organizing,
that she won her seat and
city council I'm still fighting for
justice for her home.
Community Organizing is treated as
volunteer work, but it shouldn't be.
It's why we have a five day work week,
it's why we have paid time off,
it's why everyone in this
room has the right to vote.
As we stand here today, because
community organizers fought for us.
When this country was founded,
there was no concept of overtime pay or
minimum wage child labor was not uncommon.
For people unionized and fought,
organizing major strikes to demand better.
Their actions built the momentum for
the Fair Labor Standards Act,
banning oppressive child labor and
instituting the workweek we have today.
It's time we stop taking community
organizing for granted and pay it forward.
I believe in people power I believe
that we need more grassroots leaders,
who are from the communities they serve.
People like Tina Marie,
Tom, Kendra, and Maurice,
people who won't give up
because this is their home.
Community Organizing is often treated
as volunteer work, like I said, but
it shouldn't be.
We should really focus on centering these
people in the movement for justice.
It's easy to become complacent, to feel
like everything is perfect, to do nothing.
But I'm asking you for just a few
minutes to think about where you sit
in this world even right now here at
Stanford in this very room today.
Take a look around we are sitting in an
institution with a $37 billion endowment.
Stanford's highest paid
employee makes over $8 million
hugging the western edge of
campus is sand hill road,
the epicenter of venture capital and the
most expensive street in all of America.
At the same time on El Camino rial, which
hugs the north eastern edge of campus,
dozens of Arby's are parked filled
with people just trying to get by.
Abigail couldn't afford the $600
increase from her landlord in rent,
so she and
her family of 10 moved into an RV.
Tamika and Ivan moved into an RV
when the city started cracking down
on people living in cars.
Despite both being employed,
they couldn't afford the rent.
What may look perfect
from your vantage point,
looks like how to someone who
doesn't have that privilege.
We were all raised to believe
in the American dream,
but what does the American dream mean?
If we can't all have it what does
it mean when the barriers are so
high only a few can access it and
what does it mean when
we continue to always leave
the same people behind.
Community organizers are fighting for
affordable housing, generational
wealth and voting rights because they
know that not everyone has access to it.
Living means being a part
of the world you live in,
it means taking care of each other,
it means standing up for
each other,
especially when no one else will.
That is what the American
dream should look like.
And so I'm asking you today to care
to make it better to advocate for
invested and
center the voices of community organizers,
like Tina Marie, Tom, Maurice and Kendra.
It's not about any one of
us it's about all of us,
it's about what makes us human.
Caring for each other so
let's get to work together.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> [MUSIC]